qu'est ce qui se passe
est pas quelque chose qui te choque
banon
me suis habillé d'un lac et choque pas
non non non pas du tout je suis en noir
vous êtes en droit on est en devoir tous
les deux
[Applaudissements]
qu'est-ce qu'il ya pas de changer non
c'est que ça
vous avez changé on peut pas être tous
les deux dans la même ville cette ville
est trop petite pour nous deux castaldi
tu vois bien qu'on a la même veste c'est
pas du tout bah si c'est la même veste
s'est pas portée par m
[Applaudissements]
basser et en dirait dick rivers
[Rires]
mais bon tout le
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
ça c'est vachement le tuer
[Applaudissements]
sans nucléaire
conan nous deux qui va devoir changer de
sexe ouais bah je crois que ça va être
bon
j'ai l'impression que sa victoire ici
tu veux garder cette baisse non non non
tu es ce que tu veux garder cette vidéo
est ce que tu veux garder cette dernière
nancy pourquoi je veux que tu gardes des
fonds parce que les gens dont se rendent
compte qu'elles te va beaucoup moins
bien qu'à moi d'accord mais senna lors
la tienne à l'air toute fine hélas que
c'est très très c'est peut-être on sait
décrire c'est vrai luxe d'une butte
je suis content
je suis content j'aurais commencé
l'émission tous les deux ça vient
toujours tous les temps par lee allez on
se balade un peu chaud
annoncé à la noix du besoin de bateaux
comment ça va les cherry lane à sa peau
ce jour
là bas la bombe alors
j'ai beaucoup pensé à toi mais moi aussi
comment ça va ma chérie tu as fait
plaisir
c'est la soeur de callie
[Rires]
thorne et chérie alors ça va bien je
veux
tu connais castanet
[Musique]
touche à ton cul comment ça va alors les
chaînes non je pensais beaucoup à toi
pourquoi et je me suis dit quand ça va
tranquille pas de souci dans le quartier
n'hésite pas à m'appeler j'ai un souci
il ya des échauffourées savante oui ça
va bien merci d'être là c'est plaisir
le plaisir de voir des gens
tu les vois tu devrais pas des gens et
même personne il ya une belle personne
toi tu auras tu vas faire un beau
divorce
[Rires]
face à toi
j'ai regardé un téléphone d'april
benayoun à huy qui vient d'arriver dans
l'émission j'ai vu et l écho des noirs
plus à côté de toi
puisque je fais de ce téléphone non non
non non non non non je ne peux pas j'ai
pas le mettre dans mon slip pour la
première journée sur la possible ça
c'est bien ça c'est de bien vous
sépariez
fait pas mieux j'ai paniqué je n'ai pas
lu attention ce ne l'est pas nous
apprendre l'arabe il tant que rien sinon
alors non j'ai pensé
est-ce que tu la jeunesse que tu sens
bien là ah ouais est ce que tu penses
pas
que je devrais être augmenté par rapport
aux autres chroniqueurs alors j'y pense
et
ça me paraît normal commente au niveau
de la répartie moi j'en ai pas mais vous
le savez tu prendrais le salaire de qui
tu pouvais de lanvaux pourquoi pas parce
qu'il est bien payé et dont on va lui
demander mathieu tu peux venir ça
viendra
[Applaudissements]
à
tapas bien cueillir toi non sepang non
c'est plutôt pas mal guerre ça va je
regardais ça tout à l'heure c'est pas
pareil quoi c'est vrai ah ben non